most of the mothers here have probably
never held a musical instrument before
the group for promotion of Education and
sustainable development known as groupid
sac is an organization that helps poor
Mexicans become self-sufficient it's
introducing these women and their
children to music and reading the
organization was founded by social
entrepreneur margarita bonnie is silent
America monita they go into schools and
invite people to read it's not just
about helping educate them neither be
Rocko it's also about showing them it
can be fun in addition its way of
teaching them how to live better lives
no sigh you that happened érovir mejor
no margarita Barney comes from a wealthy
family she and her staff have been
running groupid sack for 25 years it's
financed by donations she used to be a
teacher and an environmental activist
her main interest was reforestation
Alvin needed a sectoral episodic when we
went out to rural areas and so the
problems families were facing we decided
to set up our first project centre
course we're is the premier central we
developed solutions for improving
people's lives and tackling poverty in
rural areas y medios para tener una vida
mejor villagers can learn for example
how to farm fruit and vegetables
sustainably among the plants grown here
is no paleo a nutritious cactus that's
native to Mexico and is used in many
local dishes it grows well even at this
altitude
local women use what's grown here to
make moly sauce and chipotle chilies do
they package what they cook and sell it
in their centers store these days they
also supply a growing number of
supermarkets do they think you did
nearby is the village of PA de de grande
groupid sac has helped around 1,500
locals improve their lives no início mas
regalando we didn't start out with the
aim of giving people handouts we wanted
to teach them skills yucky our social
worker started out with a project for
women based on raising awareness about
the environment and health and teaching
crafts things women could relate to it
was a way of reaching out to them SI una
manera de a dryer many women in PA la
grande now grow their own produce such
as cabbage lettuce and carrots as a
local woman explains connoisseur
tulisa's you fellows opposition growing
vegetables is a big help I love it yes
it also creates jobs here in the village
I see no se you ever put Kelly wellness
but it's good for the local economy is
AE for what is in which I like 10 Mia
famiglia are you bud muchas gracias a
villagers have also learned how to
collect rainwater in cisterns that
supply their households with water
thank you please sometimes that any
rains here once a week or once every two
weeks it varies but thanks to the
cisterns we always have a supply of
water hundreds of Mexican villages have
benefited from margarita Barney's
organization yes a few personal asst is
Polaris my personal challenge right now
is to pass on the project to young
people who will approach it with
enthusiasm and who'll bring in their own
ideas for what it though gurgaon but the
main thing is that they continue the
work and that we start to see real
change by the next generation this has
always been a long-term project a lot
has already changed in pedro grande in
recent years margarita Bonnie hopes her
work will help eradicate poverty and
give children in particular a chance to
get an education and improve their
prospects but there are many other
villages in Mexico like this one that
could use her help to